good afternoon everyone my name is TJ
your student here at Yale Divinity
School and with me today is my partner
Rafael yeah my name is Rafael Faizal
I'm an LLM student at the Yale Law
School and we're coming to you today
from the interdisciplinary Center this
afternoon and we're very pleased to
introduce Paul Waldow who is an educator
a scholar and an activist working at the
intersection of animal studies ethics
law religion and cultural studies he is
currently the lead faculty member for
the anthro zoology graduate program at
Canisius College which is located in
Buffalo New York he has been the Baker
visiting professor of animal law at
Harvard Law School since 2002 and he has
led the animal law reading group at Yale
Law School and has served as director of
the center of animal and public policy
at Tufts University School of Veteran
better'n airy medicine he's played
active roles in the aar and in other
organizations in bringing about the
disciplines of animal studies and the
author of a number of books which we'll
discuss soon but I want to get right
into the conversation that's all right
well thank you all we're glad to we're
glad you're here thank you
one of the things that the group did in
this class here when we were first
getting used to your writing and some of
your work was to discuss the affection
we had for animals in our own lives and
some of the experiences of sort of first
awareness of maybe a consciousness or
this this other non-human animal that
we're dealing with and in preparation I
read some stories about you swimming
with dolphins and I wondered if you
wouldn't mind starting a little bit with
what that first experience was like and
what other sort of experiences that
might have led to early on I'm glad to
do that it's an exercise I use in the
class and it's often in the Anthropology
graduate program the very first exercise
that people have a chance to connect up
with the personal dimension but for me
lots of these experiences but the
paradigmatic one was in Huntington Beach
California when I had been learning
about the coastal dolphins not studied
well by scientists but clearly known
well by the surfers
so my brothers and I lived nearby and we
would be up on the cliffs seeing them
and so we learned to approach them and
so eventually I learned to go out and
swim with them seeing them come down the
coast and the really lovely epiphany I
think you can call it happens when I'm
out on the water by myself no it's
really a fascinating thing for a human
to go out into the deep water the swells
make it very difficult to see anything
but I can't find the Dolphins I've seen
them coming and so I'm a little
frustrated and all of a sudden I hear a
very loud choppa which is uh dolphin
surfacing and right next to me and
dolphin they don't have they have eyes
on the sides of their head so one eye
comes up about this far for me and just
trains right on my eye and I'm
speechless a rare event and I
intuitively there's a passage in Thomas
Berry's prologue to a community of
subject that where he quotes someone
about being transported when we see a
fox this was more than being transported
this was being elevated connected and we
sometimes will say phrases like that we
I know there's a light on but I can tell
you from the interaction there was such
a remarkable being on the other side and
I humbly would say I'm not really sure I
know much about that being and it lasts
all of about a second and a half but
it's about an eternity in memory and the
young dolphin realizing here's an
interesting creature I don't usually see
interacts in that wonderful intense way
for a second and a half maybe two or
three seconds and then darts away and
I'm back to the Wow I'm out in the
middle of the ocean I can't see anything
but I was just so elevated by it and I
remember that as if it's happening now
it was that intense a connection another
that I've known we'll talk about
paradigmatic dogs cats horses those
kinds of experiences so I'm gratified to
have that one and I bet people in an
animal studies class could create a
whole menagerie of these kinds of
experiences
yeah would you say that it's experiences
like these that really keep you going
and keep you motivated despite like just
a horrendous events that are constantly
happening all over the world millions of
animals being killed every second
literally would you say that connecting
to these sort of experiences that we
maybe have in our youth or or even later
sort of help you like keep the momentum
you can see it when I hear that question
I've never been asked that question
before yes I think it is important I
think if it wasn't there I would do the
same work but the fact that it happens
allows me when I start an animal studies
class to use that exercise to get people
to say here's why I'm here because one
of the keys in animal studies courses is
that the students who arrive arrive with
deep commitments great questions often
anger and the question is to create a
culture where that can be expressed but
it has to turn into a positive
constructive sort of thing where the
sharing deepens our understanding and
you learn to listen to others pain as
well not just express your own so it's a
it's a true asset that people have these
and no doubt in my life rough you know
it's a it's a an asset as well that
keeps me I would do this in any event to
put it certainly this is something to
celebrate as I do this I wonder and
you're speaking about the experience
that way and I'm also here looking at
the cover of animal studies and we had
spoken briefly and right next to a
communion of subjects and so the idea of
subjectivity is kind of coming up and I
wonder in this would you describe in
this second and a half that seems to
have this trajectory that has lived if
there's something about the kind of
eternal subjectivity that we have a
relationship to other animals through
and I don't know why one of the comments
you made was that who's who's studying
whom on this cover and I wonder if you
could say something about what you think
either this killer whale or or what kind
of whale is that I'm sorry so right
whale weather what a right whale would
be just so we can show people might be
thinking about us
or what the dolphin you think might have
been thinking about you when I first
started doing lectures on animal studies
I put this on the slide PowerPoint slide
in it so it's very clear and it's a
beautiful photo of the year for National
Geographic and I approached the author
who was excited to have this on the book
so the question I was asked so I have a
question before my students for example
the undergraduate say how many how many
mammals do you see in this picture so
they're gonna be forced to say to here
but eventually one of the questions is
going to be who's studying home here and
there are very big brains it turns out
the bigger brain is in the right well
and the I don't think there's any
question I've never been underwater with
the right well I have with other whales
and it's very clear that they're curious
like this bottlenose dolphin off the
coast of Huntington Beach California and
in terms of subjectivity you know
there's a whole field of philosophy
which makes a point of saying it's very
hard to know the mind of other humans
and be able to say with certainty that
there's consciousness there there's a
wonderfully rich field
joe-joe complicated we are this is ever
ever more complicated with other living
creatures as well but the ability to
come home it's I think something we
recognize Martin Buber Buber traced it
out as I am thou and his passages about
animals and not only I am thou but in
between man and man are unbelievably
lyrical and how he realizes he's
connecting up with his sort of
paradigmatic connection to a horse for
example in between man and man so these
experiences I think are important but
this question JJ is a wonderful one
because it opens up the universe to us
marvelously to say what else is what
else who else is with us in this journey
you're currently working on a new book
that discusses discusses the question as
to how animals invite us to think about
them could you maybe elaborate a little
bit on that idea this is a a manuscript
I've lived with for three years but I
came into the academic world and there's
an academic style in some of these books
which some people maybe celebrate I'm
sure some lament the academic style is
in a way was developed at Oxford in
in inspector of speciesism in order to
force the PhD because I was compute ly
aware of the fact that this was not a
canonical subject and it worked out fine
it was a 45-minute exam and it was
soaring and it was absolutely a
beautiful experience the animal
invitation has been written in this
manner but I recognized I don't want to
do that I want to write something more
lyrical I think Mary Ellen and John for
example there are beautiful passages in
Thomas's prologue to the communion of
subject subjects and and it's that sort
of writing I think that is all often
needed after a number of academic books
it's also a pleasure to be able to write
more freely along the lines of people
like annie dillard or martin buber just
there are so many wonderful writers and
the ability to communicate what it is
that each of us is a very complex animal
experiences when we encounter others
human or otherwise is a really rich
tradition that I'd like to explore more
so in a way I will finish at this summer
that's the commitment and it is a
question of softening the language
actually perhaps expanding it and
enriching it in some way so the point
here is to recognize that in countless
ways when a human encounters another
there is a kind of possible experience
with humans of course we all know that
deeply but with many other living beings
in this society with companion animals
horses dogs cats but I gave you the
earlier example of with the free
swimming dolphin who certainly was my
equal and more and so to try to find
language that honors that and also
brings us all home to the fact that if
you're open to this you will find it
everywhere neighborhood backyard out in
the ocean you can find it truly
everywhere so I wanted to use some sort
of creative phrase and the animal
imitation attempts to capture that I
wonder if we could walk back just a
little bit and I know that you were a
trial attorney schooled in the dark arts
of civil litigation and
I can't help but wonder I know now your
position in is in academia but was there
ever a time you thought maybe that the
courtroom was the place to do work on
behalf of non-human animals the answer
to that is no although I often I was a
with a very sophisticated litigation
firm and there were such wonderful
skills and the people ahead of me that
you couldn't help by but by osmosis
become quite competent and I rose to be
the administrative partner but and I did
lots of trials but I I had relentlessly
human clients it was later only later
that I said if you get I would have
loved have been a lawyer and having that
dolphin as a client that when that would
have brought out some zealous advocacy
but I realized fairly quickly that the
clash that is the essence of litigation
zealous advocacy on each side hopefully
a resulting in the truth was not my
style I was much more interested in the
irenic approach that you find in the
academic world where you get people to
walk together and it was something that
showed up in my style as a lawyer and
although things went well I was I became
a partner very early and and they very
generously compensated me when I was the
first partner ever to leave this
marvelous law firm they were surprised
but I wanted to go do this because this
is like stepping off a cliff and falling
down for me the chance to take people of
goodwill to work on our relationship to
the entire universe to not only the
non-human animals and the humans but of
course to the ecosystems in our rich
place I find this the most I find it a
richly spiritual experience and this
isn't a person who goes around using the
word spiritual too often but I it is
clearly that and it is so engrossing for
me that I never think of myself as doing
anything but starting again so I didn't
I don't want to start again in a law in
a courtroom one of my first students at
BC did a paper on Jim
pansies testifying in court my first
response was what is a chimpanzee doing
in court this is not a good situation
and of course you could tape it but we
wanted to work out the technical details
of that but for me the encounters I want
with and on behalf of other living
beings is out in the world on a walk on
a swim that sort of thing so no I don't
want to go back into the courtroom even
if I can defend that dolphin and Paul as
a professor you have one foot in the
academic world but as we've heard you're
a former attorney you're the president
of the religion and animals Institute
and you were also the legal director of
the great a project so you also
definitely have food in the sort of
world of practice how important do you
think it is is it personally for you to
be involved in both worlds I think it's
a matter of being informed to keep a
foot in each of those worlds it my trait
seems to be to move into a field like
law and try to expand what's offered
there and then to bridge it over to
other fields like religion when we think
of our work on religion and ecology
religion and animals it has been so
gratifying to see how natively people
take to it and for me another step here
is to bring in to bring fields into
dialogue and I'm aware that in these
first wave forms of animal studies in
anthropology and religion and animals
that they're often isolated into the
tradition of discourse that they've
inherited now now in religion and
animals for example almost nobody talks
to the law and animals people and yet
there is great expertise over there and
vice versa and if we can combine those
two fields and get benefits we can
combine four fields and get better
benefits we can combine the entire
Academy so the closing chapter in animal
studies is this attempt to say so what
would what would the university look
like if we didn't just do the dualism
thing of Sciences on the one hand and
arts and the humanities on the other
what would happen if we have a third
branch that helped us get out into the
rest of the world and to me that's not a
very
easy thought to think about but it is a
wonderful thought idea to try to have
thought experiment as it were and so I
think I realized that the attempt here
is a very preliminary attempt and I want
to continue to explore that how we get
experts from these different domains to
cross fertilize to really work together
because my sense is we see much further
much much further by doing that I think
in that vein some of your writing is
about I don't know if finding a new
language is the right way to put it but
but maybe the same language in new
conversations I don't know if that's an
apt way to put it but I think you you do
have some interest in using language in
new ways in order to do this well let me
give you a little background for that
first of all I think the whole approach
is to create a gentle culture where
people feel that they can venture and
even be wrong but safe on ideas about
the future on ideas about how to protect
on on their deep concerns I work in a
science department where scientists
teach students to use phrases like
humans and animals now that phrase is a
complicated phrase from the scientific
vantage point humans are primates
mammals vertebrates these are all animal
categories we're just as much animal as
any other animal but and scientists
should be on board for that instantly so
when I arrived at Canisius I said to the
chair of the department let's let's
finish the Scientific Revolution let's
go all the way but they struggled that's
typical of primates though they're
invested in the traditional language
that's like well welcome to the world
and so some of the language games that I
play if I can use that phrase is just
trying to stretch us stretch myself I've
embarrassed myself for two decades now
standing up in public and saying
non-human animals the more than human
world these sorts of phrases and I'm
always targeted I mean clearly
identified as an activist and but for me
the basic piece of wisdom is listen
everybody's an activist on this point if
you're using the phrase humans and
animals you're an activist but you're so
joined by so many others that
notices this agenda but that is agenda
ridden I can at least defend myself by
saying you scientists I'm using your
agenda I want to use scientific language
how about it and now I've sort of forked
them into this position of oh oh my god
I have to agree with him or I have to
disagree and be unscientific and that's
a lovely place to put people who aspire
to critical thinking and it's where I'm
put sometimes and it's a question of
language can be such a well it's a house
of being a house of new being if I
didn't quote misquote Heidegger in your
writings you seem to really show a great
deal of optimism as to the role that
academia can play and we were sort of
wondering in our class here as to why
you're so positive about the role that
academia can have we had this lunch
discussion today was closing a little
bit of this it I I had the good fortune
to be raised by two very nice parents in
a big Catholic family that was poor so
we we developed some skills of caring
about each other that was very effective
it was particularly my mother's
graciousness and kindness that rubbed
off on all eight children this is a
fascinating fact and in the face of the
fact that our Father was such a powerful
individual you would have thought we had
all turned out like him no no we all
turned it like the really powerful
parent our gracious loving mother so it
is it works and we were discussing it
the lunchtime session to do that what
really works is you you need multiple
discourses to talk to a wide range of
people and when you go into a humanity
that is invested in one discourse you
best show them that you respect their
discourse work with them
so that if you're working with Buddhists
talk to them in terms that Buddhists
understand my mentor was the philosopher
of religion John hick and if you asked
John what his work was about he'd say I
want to describe a religious tradition
in a way that the adherents say yep
that's us in a way what I'm after is
when I'm talking to people getting them
to realize they get to use their
discourse I'll try to bridge back I'll
try to let us all be ourselves in this
conversation to see if we can't come to
that really foundational feature that
the animal invitation speaks to and that
is if you are open
to this it's a marvelous world it's a
completely marvelous world so in some
ways I'm just using language to sort of
create bridges back and forth so that
over time we can begin to talk in a
trusting way and then we go exploring
yeah I wonder about that the well you
said before about maybe I don't know if
it's fair to say even your own voice you
want to start to change in the sense in
the way that you put your information
out into the world from academic books
and now looking forward prospectively
into writing in a different voice it
does that have anything to do with the
kind of either your own spiritual
journey or your own spiritual progress
or is this still like the ongoing
conversation or invitation maybe that
you're feeling from the non-human animal
world too we've had a couple talks today
about how interdisciplinary work is so
difficult because you're always at a
disadvantage so that when I'm in a law
conference I'm with people who do only
law and I'm doing it 1/6 the time and I
teased at lunch saying I'm I sometimes
will say I'm incompetent in six
different fields because I really am
with experts I I want the language to
help us I know the academic language can
sometimes I'm teaching an animal ethics
course right now and one of the
exercises for my students is what does
this academic language about ethics have
to do with your real life that's one
that's the very first exercise and these
are people who come for ethical reasons
but they often Balch at employing
deontological language or utilitarian
concepts or virtue ethics so we try to
get beyond to people like Martha
Nussbaum and her capabilities approach
because it's so focused on the actual
individuals features or there are
wonderful ethicists around and so for me
teaching is about using the skills that
people bring and those that I have to
somehow meet and begin to work together
I'm acutely aware that in the 12th
conversation we're doing so much better
than we're doing in the first but I
can't get to the 12th unless I go
through the first a second and so I
always want it to be an invitational
soft
let people let me let others be wrong
but venture forth why this is important
and share that that that safety creates
great educational dynamics but it just
takes half a term half a semester to let
it happen and when it's going you start
to realize it here we go and it's it's a
gratifying thing when it happens maybe
if we go back to your last book animal
studies and maybe also discuss more
specifically animal law I'd be
interested in hearing how you see the
two concepts animal rights and animal
studies interrelate I just did a paper
the opening paper for the journal that
the graduate program will publish
student-led but I asked them for
permission and I wanted them to approve
this and I'm in good standing with them
so they did approve this that I could
have the opening article at the
invitational article and it's called
animal studies in the key of animal
rights animal rights is a dirty swear
word in many science departments you say
that were people will turn and walk away
from you this is true of some churches
as well but I wanted because I have good
standing and it's known that I'm a to
sort of walk with me person I wanted to
use that phrase I don't use that phrase
very often in public although it is the
title of this book animal rights because
Oxford University Press wanted this
title sure I like the term
it's just that isn't very productive in
mixed company if you understand my
meaning
so I think that this is the real
revolution animal studies using our
capacious ethical abilities scientific
abilities abilities to think critically
cross culturally interdisciplinarily to
try to understand our relationship with
all the other living beings for heaven
sakes they're ubiquitous they're all
around they're everywhere but we've
ignored them in our academic world
I think animal rights is an attempt to
do a revolution and it's a nice sort of
minor revolution I don't mean to demean
it by that what I mean by that is we're
using powerful conceptuality that we
have deployed to protect human beings
from horrific human on human harms
is the really great use of the term of
the legal rights system it has worked
well and we want to deploy it across the
line it's very creative but it will only
apply to some of the nonhumans if we can
be informed about these nonhumans in not
necessarily saying oh they're like us
cognitive superstars great great
wonderful status to be in at least two
arrogance as all of us know the issue is
that there are many other living beings
that matter immensely immensely but
won't qualify as cognitive superstars
animal studies can recognize that far
sooner than animal rights can because
we're deploying this superstar technique
that we want and if we lit out a world
where all we did was use our legal
rights to protect humans and we used
many other forms of our ability to be
caring living beings to protect
non-human animals such that it was
effective and fundamental I'd say I
don't have any problem with that at all
I'd love to have legal rights for other
living beings but if it doesn't work
that's not the end of the game there are
many many other mechanisms that we have
these other tools that we have in the
legal toolbox to help sort of further
animals interests legislation it's quite
possible for example some countries have
prohibitions on ownership it doesn't
involve the protected animals and having
rights but you see we can use our
ability to self-regulate
in these powerful ways to say they're
not going to tolerate people owning
chimpanzees this is now it's gonna work
we're gonna want them in their own
communities where we protect them
elephants can certainly protect from be
protected with this sort of things well
without having to carry individual
rights it's a very complex thing in our
legal system to have an individual
non-human carrying this powerful shield
it can work we can make it work we're
clever this way but it really strikes me
that the legal system is truly an
incredibly diverse toolbox that you
reach in and you pull out problem
appropriate tools to solve that what the
dilemma in front of you but going beyond
that legal toolbox there are so many
things in our religious communities are
we can learn to talk and see things we
can teach our children one of my
favorite coaches David auras lovely
comment about them educate
unless it's of a certain kind can merely
equip humans to be more effective
vandals of the earth well that's a good
description of sort of modern education
except now we could bring along animal
studies and you could see why animal
studies is the Revolutionists like let's
stop that let's stop that we're harming
ourselves we're harming the other living
beings let's be more Aldo Leopold
responsible member of the land community
not Conqueror responsible citizens that
is in responsible member these are
fundamental concepts that actually
appealed to all of us if you're in a if
you recognize who's in your community
and obviously some non-human animals are
in our community I'm gonna ask you a
question I'm I'm guessing you've been
asked as the first or second question
from most church groups or other groups
you've spoken to after they hear all
students of your ideas and what you want
to say you can probably guess what the
question is well what can I do what can
I do right now in my community in my
place and I'm not asking you that
necessarily for me but I'm almost asking
your opinion on that question that's a
very enabling question I mean that's a
plea for help me help me see just get
away from the intellectual 'ti here
please yes this is the this is the
foundational question it's the reason I
wrote the book in a way because I knew
that there were people who wanted to
come into the academic world and ask
that sort of question but it's it's
hidden in there it's the third of the
three major questions what is the answer
first of all it's act locally their
reach live in this world if we take care
of our local living beings watch how
really-really fecund to this is in terms
of possibilities if we wanted to teach
someone let's say the big high order
ecological notions of ecosystems etc and
population dynamics and those sorts of
things and you said well let's go out
and observe the local deer in the forest
this is typical in New England where I
live for example and if you got them to
pay attention to the individual deer you
can learn to recognize them as
individuals and and then you ask them
well what sort of what sort of habitat
do they need now you build from the idea
of recognizing the individuals that you
see is important to the fact that they
have a habitat which if you destroy you
destroy the individuals even though you
might say I would never harm
individual but you will destroy their
habitat so you now built into the sort
of nate natural individual to individual
connection with the deer the concept the
larger concept of ecosystems for me the
one-on-one basis of our ethics leads
wonderfully well opens door after door
to the larger concepts that
environmental protection requires it is
elegant the environmental work it's just
that it's often irrelevant to
individuals in their daily life is like
let's go why would you pick up the trash
here because this is the local deers
habitat and now what lesson have you
learned you've really started to figure
certain things out that the the
interconnection that's so true of so
many things but somehow our ideas don't
lead us to that and if people start with
environmental things they often get it
but some don't but Animal Protection has
this extra personal connection that lets
you add on connect up open the sort of
transporting corridors to these
beautiful large concepts which are quite
important it's just that they're not so
existentially compelling at first for
many people an animal protection is in
your writings he also emphasized the
sort of importance of education when it
comes to maybe guiding our our behavior
and you point out that over 150 law
schools nowadays in the u.s. offer at
least one course on animal law and so
what we were discussing here in our in
our course was as to why yale law school
doesn't offer such a class and even
worse why it declined and offer a
donation of 1 million dollars that would
have enabled it to offer such a course
what would you say
could be the motivations that have led
to such a decision I don't actually know
I'd love to ask the animals who made it
and say why why not but but I will tell
you that I think the people who made
that decision do not recognize that the
dynamism of the course is something that
feeds the rest of Education it creates
certain sorts of virtues that deploy
in other fields I'm not sure what the
answer to that is it baffles me and
especially because having done two
reading groups here it was an incredible
experience for me
partly because when you go to the school
of the order of Yale or Harvard the very
high quality schools there is a kind of
level of exchange that is possible that
is a richer and a different experience
than I get for example in certain other
places I'm trying to say this as gently
as possible and that is very gratifying
for somebody who aspires to try to think
carefully
honestly humbly which is really a fun
thing to do and those of you who've
written books will know writing books is
just a I mean unbelievably humbling
exercise because it takes so long and I
will tease and say all the talent all
the talent is in the finishing none of
it's in the start none of it's in three
quarters the way through it's all in the
finishing because it's so hard to finish
these sorts of things and for me just
the chance to engage is honestly in my
own taking responsibility for my own
learning which is what I will constantly
say to my undergraduates but always to
my graduates i educate graduates on the
premise that each of them is unique and
I want to find her place his place it's
almost always her 85% women and all the
animal studies courses this group is the
only group I have ever been in an animal
study centered focus that is gender
balance it's the only one in 20 plus
years of this now I was looking around
thinking that's really wonderful so the
point is how do I find the graduate
students teach them as individuals learn
them etc that takes a certain sort of
softness and and patience and as you can
see I talking is a wonderfully enjoyable
experience from this for this primate
yet listening is even more profitable
I wonder about the not that there's an
end game or whatever but I don't know I
wonder is there what is what is it maybe
in in the you know in the work that you
do you would see as being say in the
next ten years as a big success
nice question TJ here I think this is a
kind of success first of all there are
three schools here this is not the kind
of thing that happened usually I'm
usually talking to the law school I'm
usually talking to div school I've got
three powerhouse schools here I'm
thinking this is that and I John and
Mary Evelyn know well that I was enabled
by the religion and oncology people to
do this work it has launched this
forward in a way that I could have never
done on my own the fact that this so
beautifully administered and this
community has grown so in such a healthy
organic way and the fact that the animal
studies work can be integrated as part
of that has given it a respectability
and access to these sorts of things it
is a natural it took you Mary Ellen it
took you a millisecond when I asked you
about this the animals conference to say
yes good let's do it
I thought oh that's we're refreshing so
for me the the the endgame here is a
short-term end game in the sense of
getting the academic world to deploy
it's it's great skills when we're
responsible and not to create more
effective vandals of the earth with our
tremendously great capacious
technological skills but instead to
create something that is technologically
proficient and protects us and gives us
all the more skills but to deploy those
skills in the communion of subjects way
this is really what I'm after and you
can notice that I have a communal style
I'm aware I'm member of nested
communities some of them are nonhumans I
wonder why do always think of myself as
a human not as a mammal I actually am a
member of the Nano community but I
wasn't trained to do that so I'm trying
to learn I'm not so good at this no but
the point is that education can teach us
that we will shape we will shape
socially construct our self
understanding but we are in charge of
this and we can do this in an inclusive
fair way not an autistic leave the world
way that pretends that somehow this was
designed for us if so this is not the
best design for us if that really was
the case what's wonderful is that we do
fit in wonderfully and we have the
ability to protect ourselves and nurture
our larger community we really have that
ability that Thomas Berry's phrase the
larger community is the one that just
probably most excites me gets me
furthest along and I realize I am a
member of a larger community it is not
just an idea it is a reality it happens
every time I walk which is why I walk
every day because I want to be back in
my world I really do I think you really
nicely sort of highlighted the
significance of making this step toward
what you also called in your writing the
second wave of animal law but I would
sort of also wonder where do you see the
challenges of this more
interdisciplinary approach to animal
studies yeah the second wave of animal
laws I think an important phase in
essence it is that it becomes more more
interdisciplinary it reaches out across
other domains Sciences has an important
place in modern law but it's often been
used as the handmaiden that's not the
right phrase it's often been used as the
tool of oppression if you know some of
the pre Brown versus Board of Education
discussions of the use of science was to
to assert a racial inferiority but
science is relentlessly powerful
questioning everything and it strikes me
that it strikes me that we really have
such great potential available to us if
we work together in a very humble way
I'm constantly trying to get law to talk
to religion because in in the animals in
religion group there's a dynamism that
is beautiful to see there isn't a
religion in ecology group and it's a
question of how do we cross link I don't
I'm not at all expert in that I am
willing to try and it is a it is a it is
a slow process this
it is a risky thing to do animal studies
and think I'm going to get a PhD and get
a hundred job offers that is not what's
happening lots of us who have these
positions have really had to pierce
through this and be disadvantaged it's
not I don't look to a disadvantage and
obviously I haven't been in some sense
as ultimately but I'm aware that my
students are at risk so I'm trying to
create in them realism but the one of
the reasons I'm most interested in the
academic world is I want to here's a
good use of cloning clone our program
get others to attempt out-compete us
because what we do at Canisius is
powerful and good and if somebody's out
competing us Wow is that not to be
applauded so for me if someone says what
if they get better than we are it's like
great then we'll have to catch up and
for me this is the point of education is
to kind of get a this multiplication
going and it's you can see this starting
to happen but it goes very very slowly
yeah it's hearing words in the realm of
law and academia like humble humility
it's it's not something I hear every day
in those realms and so I just wanted to
I guess maybe personally what have been
the advantages either the sort of the
source of finding this discovery and
where does this come from that working
in this way looking for humility looking
for you know being humble in the way
that we go about this does that come
from any sort of personal spiritual
findings discoveries or beliefs or is
that just what has worked I mean is it
is it almost practical humility or how
is that for you I think probably others
can answer that better I don't think
there's any question that John Mary
Ellen the two of you by working together
have modeled that so often for me we've
talked about this before I also have
this style somewhat natively and so I
modeled that for others but they pick it
up and they teach me more there are
really remarkable people involved in the
animal studies movement and I'm situated
well enough to have very very good
friends in the dynamism that
from that and calling up someone like
Marc Bekoff or Bernie Rowland who are
senior players and have done amazing
things but to talk with them and get
their ideas I think part of this is
simply recognizing that if we create a
community I'll tell you a story that
illustrates this point we would create a
community we see so much further and
this is the story I grew up in a house
of five Kath of eight children five boys
we weren't allowed to go on the roof
which meant we were up there quite
regularly so we're standing on the roof
we're all quite interested in the Stars
and one of the things that happened was
all five of us standing it's just that
the Sun has just set you're starting to
see the stars come out and people are
saying see this see that see this it
wasn't that we saw five times as far
with five of us we saw a thousand times
as far because number one would say you
see mercury on the horizon someone else
will say yes that's right and then
someone else would say build on that how
about this and the first person says no
I didn't see that we build on that we're
building back work back and forth and
back and forth these are five loving
brothers and within two hours we're
seeing a thousand times more than we
would have seen if we were there alone
it wasn't five times as far the
communication helped us that's a model
for what happens and really really well
functioning communities in the academic
world you reinforce and everybody stands
on shoulders shoulder shoulders
shoulders and it really becomes dynamic
in a way you cannot touch on your own
that's something intuitively we all know
because we experience it and it's the
sort of thing you cannot force it you
must let it happen but as it happens
it's it's worth celebrating that's
that's another invitation in the world
where you see scholars working in that
truly beautiful and fulfilling way
nurturing I think is the way to describe
it I would think that many people get
invited if I may say so by their own
domestic cat domesticated animals their
own companion animals with whom they
grew up and you emphasize also that it's
an important step in the second wave
that we sort of maybe try to keep our
love obviously with our like animal
friends but also maybe not
to let them distort our review of all
the thousands and millions of other
species that are out there can you maybe
shed some more light on that thought
yeah I've written about the companion
animal paradigm driving modern animal
law now this is an open door and that's
to be welcomed and for heaven's sakes
the personal encounters and the
invitations literally invitations from
dogs with their play boughs for example
or cats wiping you going by you saying
come here these are to be built upon the
problem is evidenced by this story I was
asked to I was part of the American Bar
Association's animal law group one of
the founders and so I'm asked to give a
talk so I'm gonna come in and talk
relentlessly like I'm talking now about
academic situations and they're yawning
I'm on the phone I don't really know
that but I'm sure they were yawning
because all they wanted to hear about
was cat intensive dog intensive
proposals they weren't interested in
this broad Wow education dynamism stuff
and I thought that's not good that's
these are powerful policy brokers for
the future but I trying to break them
through to this so there is a down side
let's not overstate that there's an up
side that's totally worth keeping and so
I'm always cautious about trying to say
here's an advantage but let's not let it
be the show the point is to take this
going back to the five brothers analogy
and let it be just one of the brothers
that helps us get there get there get
there get there
and so companion animals needs to be a
player it is at the core of am through
all G slash animal studies this is a
political correctness I don't like the
term anthro zoology
I prefer animal studies I still got the
job leading the anthro zoology programs
like thank heaven but I think animal
studies is the more generic way to
describe this because it allows us to be
in we are animals and we're studying the
others and that wonderful balance that
when were not well behaved if I might
say it that way when we're really having
all of our integrities in place studying
other living beings is a powerful and
good thing for us that's all the
evidence shows that it is unbelievably
integrating for us to recognize we live
in a multi-species world I was reading
some of the examples like in India and
in other places where either inherently
or through activism or through law some
of these changes are happening and I
guess if you could share with us what
you have seen as current or more recent
successes of shifts of either small or
wider communities with this regard and
and how it might have gone about or if
there's anything we can take from those
I'm I often use this quote and I use
this to enter that question TJ hard to
start revolutions harder still to
sustain them hardest of all to win them
and when you've won them that's when the
real difficulties begin that's from
larvae venom Headey that's in Geo
Pontecorvo's Battle of Algiers movie
fabulous movie in the history of film
quite an important film but that helped
me see that when we're trying to move a
social movement along we're to the
sustaining it now where it's harder to
sustain that that's what we're doing
right now and there are some really
important legislative there are
literally around the world thousands of
pieces of protective legislation going
into place literally proposed hundreds
going into place right you might say and
this is an important task we've got in
education all sorts of classes in
geography I was mentioning earlier today
literature these are and if you look at
the history of art the place of
non-human animals in art is fabulously
important and really very revealing of
how ubiquitous they are in our lives and
so for me that the successes aren't
always just in the animal law world
TJ although they're there but they come
very slowly they really come slowly and
it's a pendulum sort of things where
things get undone this happens the
passage of the Animal Welfare Act in
1966 was wonderfully important it has
been truly eviscerated in many respects
nonetheless they're still in place the
aya cook the institutional Animal Care
and Use Committee approach which
has some important protections not even
close to enough and we need to build on
them and go much much further but
they're there I I think in terms of laws
I think it's actually much more on the
legislative side than on the litigation
side litigation is a complex strategy
and those of us who have tried cases
know you can lose cases on a thousand
basis you can lose it on unbeli you can
not even know why you lose it
legislation is difficult though because
the Advocate of the litigation approach
Steve wise will say I can't get into
legislatures they'll never listen to me
so I'm gonna go into the courts because
I'm a lawyer and they'll have to listen
to me
Wow okay that says something I still
think legislation has all sorts of
potential it's probably off continent
for us mostly right now the European
Union is very far ahead and you find
lots of very interesting proposals
happening in India and China very
complex societies in their own right to
be sure but you can gather these
different legislative achievements
around the world and bring them home and
say let's let's let's try to work on
this sort of thing but we all know that
the the political dynamics in the US are
very caught up in a certain polarized
debate over many topics and it's very
tough so if we can't win the Volt's
perhaps we can steal the minds of the
children maybe that's the education
approach that point I'm making is that
sometimes older primates get set and you
can't undo them even with patience you
can't but you can in education because
there we're often working on Socratic
methods are just in the relevance of
information or come back to the science
channel motto question everything it's
very dynamic
educational tool question everything if
it's good it will stand up and so it's a
beautiful thing to try to implement that
sort of critical thinking approach in
education because it only makes us
stronger in every other field of
education that we endeavor to to achieve
them maybe another approach for animal
advocates would be to join sort of
efforts with maybe groups that have
tried to advocate the interests of other
oppressed groups do you think this is a
sort of helpful or even fee
Cybil way that animal protection people
could take yes it's certainly feasible
I'll give you no history an example
there was a woman who came to study at
Tufts when I was the director of the
program she already had PhD she had for
20 years been the director of a national
of national campaigns for a major
feminist group she said I spent 20 years
of my life on the women's issue and I'm
now going to spend the next 20 years of
my life on the nonhuman animal issue and
I thought that's great
but there's a fundraising reality for
nonprofits that you rarely like to share
your your donor base with others even if
there's even if they're doing exactly
the work you're doing there's a sort of
its infrastructure in search of self
perpetuation we just need to raise money
we're not giving our names to others
some people some nonprofits do but it's
a relentless problem with nonprofits not
cooperating with each other we see this
in every social movement it's just
tragic in the extreme but I think
there's a sort of self-interest issue
Raffaele that that makes cooperation
with other social movements complicated
but you can see from the fact that this
woman did such fantastic work on one
social cause that she understood helping
she didn't give up her work but she came
she continued to work very for the UN
women in Afghanistan but she was
becoming skilled in the other side as
well and so I she her name is Jennifer
Jackman and she held holds out great
hope for me but I know that that's not
statistically common in the groups that
I see but I will tell you that the
graduate students I see would say sure
I'll do that it's quite evident that
they're very very interested in
protecting humans and now they're trying
to work in another domain but they don't
give up their human protection
commitments this way so if there is a
way in which this is already happening
but there is this a sort of institution
level incentive to not cooperate to well
we're getting close to time but if I
could ask one final question I'm curious
what you've done so far that you'd be
most happy to tell that dolphin that you
accomplished a lovely question
well let me take it back to the personal
because I think this is relentlessly a
part of life
I deal regularly with activists I get
calls from people who want to be animal
law lawyers they get to calls people who
want to do direct action I'm very
interested in meeting and talking to
them I'm a deep ly committed peace
activist and I non-violence a has to be
the way so I get a chance with direct
action people to communicate this with
them so I I'm quite interested in
talking to activists but the piece of
advice that I give that I'm alluding to
here is have a good personal life I have
the great fortune to be married to a one
my best friend
and I know that that's a kind of solace
in my life because there will be defeats
along the way so that one of the truly
important things for me is to keep my
personal life walk meditate be in touch
with good people celebrate and don't
take myself my failures too seriously
after all it's just a I'm just one
person
so there is a way in which that has
worked Marvel's in my life I have a much
calmer especially if I meditate twice
per day that seems to help amazingly
because you don't it do you recognize
how eager ego ego ego so one of the
things that matters most to me it TJ I
would say to the dolphin listen if if we
will just humble up and do the best we
can take ourselves seriously but not too
seriously and have good interpersonal
relationships we can pay those forward
that's to me the fundamental strategy
that I want and that I think that is
what it takes to do activism on behalf
of any group is because activism in this
friction II world goes too slowly this
is the reality that I think and every
cause I've been in it's too slowly
that's it but there are successes and
they are so worth celebrating
they are yeah well thanks so much for
being here with us Paul and for sharing
your thoughts and also personal
experiences that you've had well thank
you Ron thank you very much